today's question comes from tiffany in
north kentucky
she visits daveramsey.com to ask my
fiance's mother controls his finances
he was married for 10 years and his wife
spent a lot of his money and his mother
stepped in after the divorce and pays
his bills
he's 37. oh crap we right that's
what i'm saying we are getting married
in three months and i've been trying to
take over finances but his mother will
not allow it and he won't stand up to
his mom
the only thing we argue about is the
finances i said we should open up a
checking account but he doesn't want to
close his current checking account that
he shares with his mommy
he wants me to come to his bank which i
don't want to is i don't want his mother
in my finances as well
is there a way to compromise on this
yes he has to divorce his mother before
he can marry
[Laughter]
it's you otherwise i don't want to hurt
tiffany's feelings but too late
run run jerry it's a fire i'm trying to
think like
dude run
there's tiffany if this was your
daughter
asking you this question you would tell
her do not
marry a mama's boy a 37 year old mama's
boy
this is going to be a long life his
mother is a trip
and he invites her in his suitcase
god almighty bye
felicia tiffany walk away
walk away i don't even know what to say
to this i don't know what to say to this
oh no there's a that's a throwback dude
this is throwback thursday no this is i
want to hug tiffany north kentucky is
what this is
oh i mean it's so easy to poke fun out
because it's just so sad and ridiculous
but
the truth is that tiffany you've gone
you spent way too much time and invested
too much already trying to get a guy to
be a grown man that's not apparently
willing to yeah
and and the the deal is his mom probably
loves him
and saw that he wrecked the plane the
last time and she didn't want him to
take off again
and for good or for worse that's
it's not helpful but it is what it is so
you happen to be female and the last one
was two
yeah and this and that's bothering his
mother yeah somebody got between
her and her baby once and it won't
happen again but um
you you have a line here that says i
don't want his mom and my finances too
clear as day this is what you're signing
up for so if you go through this in
three months
then you are inviting mom into your
flight it's your fault yeah if you go
through this yeah so
he's not your fiance anymore and when he
moves out of his mother's house
and takes control of his own life and
becomes a man again um if this was a
woman i would say exactly the same thing
an adult becomes an adult there we go
okay
i mean if um if this was the dad
controlling the daughter 37 year old
daughter's finances it's the exact same
thing
exactly so when you this is it's just
toxic and weird
right and moms dads don't do that
let your 30 year olds fly baby bird no
no don't let them fly
shove them out yes 37 failure to launch
if you look around your home and your
child doesn't have special needs that's
a whole different thing
and you have the account number to your
37 year old kid
you need to go to church you need to go
do something man go find a therapist
call your friend and say hey buddy do
you have the
the checking account number you're a 37
year old kid can you imagine
what winston cruz would say if i asked
to have the account number
access to their checking accounts for
rachel and winston can you pause
you can you see winston's face the look
right now i can see the look
yes the storm cloud that would come
across his eyes
he he would just he would answer you
over his shoulder as he
gathered his children and headed to the
car
and he too would say bye felicia
i'm out dave yeah i just pop out i
just i don't understand it and again
this is heartbreaking tiffany and i know
you've driven this thing right up to the
edge of the cliff before you
you're about to hit the gas and drive
off the edge but stop
you know bridge out bridge out bridge
out man
bye felicia
sometimes these blinds.com questions man
these are fantastic
yeah well they are and um
you know i think you're the best part of
this whole that whole discussion is what
you said
and that's to moms and dads don't do
don't do this stop
make your kids grow up you are not
helping no you're not helping
in part okay i understand he screwed up
in his firm or divorce
and i understand she stepped in to help
him get but she shouldn't have even at
that point been on the account
she should have just guided him and said
i know you're wounded right now i'll
walk with you
and i'll coach you just like i would do
for you that's right my friend
yeah but i don't need to be on your
account right
in order to help you recover from your
misspending wife that you got divorced
from i can walk beside you as your
friend
and do that as two adults instead of me
taking over your finances as if you are
completely
inept and the moment my son comes to me
and says hey i
have found the next person and we're
getting engaged
you start that transfer you should have
that should have never been in the first
place right you start
immediately your hands are off yeah but
instead no she doesn't he doesn't
he no oh man my mom couldn't wait to
transfer
responsibility from my wife like this is
your problem
here's his birth certificate the social
security card get out of here
man it was hey uh i'm sorry sheila this
is your problem now
this one's on you good luck with this
one i'll be cheering for you
all right that's right see you at
christmas
yeah um
and guys um
if you're not gonna have a backbone
don't get married don't get married
don't bring somebody else into your
dysfunction
yeah this is there's just so much
here there's so many people here that
need to be addressed
but um wow
and this is classic too the the other
thing that's classic
and you said it earlier is the
it starts out with love and good
intentions
always man most of the time there was
nothing this mom did not set out to harm
this
little boy no but she did i have to ask
what role did this type of of intrusive
parent
play in his first marriage
what type of intrusive parent has set up
a 40 year old kid that doesn't know how
to pay his bills
mama's a test pilot for a broom factory
huh i mean
man i am not going to check the
um the uh youtube clips after this one
well we might as well because they
generally agree with us because that's
why they hang out there
it'd be funny though oh my god tiffany
run baby run
so tiffany is supposed to say bye-bye
felicia is that how this works
tiffany's just supposed to hit the gas
and turn the other way
oh tiffany hit the u-turn spin out
that's right hit the gas
okay wave in your view mirror see ya
bubba